Brush like a Pro.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: CNN, MSNBC, AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ARE WORKING
TOGETHER TO PUSH A FALSE STORY A
SPIRIT OF THE THE HOUR, EACH
NETWORK PUT ON "NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTERS.
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION WAS
OFFICIALLY CREATED TO UNCOVER
RUSSIAN HACKING AND THE AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY, BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT
IT IS ANYMORE.
IT IS NOW AN ALL-PURPOSE PROBE
INTO THE PRESIDENT.
HIS PERSONAL AND FINANCIAL LIFE
DESIGNED TO MAKE US FEEL SAFER,
I HOPE YOU FEEL SAFER.
YESTERDAY, FBI AGENTS RAIDED THE
OFFICE OF MICHAEL COHEN, THAT'S
A PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL LAWYER
APPARENTLY LOOKING FOR EVIDENCE
ABOUT PAYMENTS TO STORMY
DANIELS, THE STAR WHO IS NOT
FROM RUSSIA AND DID NOT HACK OUR
ELECTION IN ANY CASE.
STEVE SCHMIDT NOTED THAT MANY OF
THE CONSTITUTION WOULD BE
THRILLED BY THIS.
THEY ALWAYS HATED THE
BILL OF RIGHTS, THOSE GUYS.
>> IF YOU LISTEN CLOSELY TONIGHT
>> IF YOU LISTEN CLOSELY TONIGH
TONIGHT, YOU CAN HEAR THE FAINT
APPLAUSE FROM HEAVEN OF THIS
COUNTRY'S FOUNDING FATHERS WHO
BEQUEATHED TO US A NATION OR THE
RULE OF LAW IS SUPREME.
WE ARE A NATION OF LAWS.
>> Tucker: THE FOUNDERS WANTED
TO KNOW, DID THE MONEY GO TO
STORMY DANIELS?
WHAT HAPPENED TO STORMY DANIELS?
JONATHAN TURLEY AS A
PROFESSIONAL AT
GEORGE WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY'S
SCHOOL OF LAW AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
I THINK YOU WERE ONE OF THE
TRUSTWORTHY PEOPLE IN THIS
CONVERSATION.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOUR POLITICS
ARE.
I DON'T THINK WE AGREE
POLITICALLY, BUT I TRUST HER
LEGAL VIEWS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS RAID ON
THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYER'S OFFICE?
>> PART OF THIS IS OF COHEN IS
MAKING.
HE PLAYERS HIS RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN A LAWYER AND A BUSINESS
PARTNER.
THAT'S DANGEROUS UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES, BUT PARTICULARLY
IF YOU'RE GOING TO EVOKE CLIENT
ATTORNEY PRIVILEGE IS.
HE MAY HAVE TROUBLE WITH THAT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE STORMY
DANIELS AGREEMENT, IT'S STILL
NOT CLEAR WHAT ROLE HE'S PLAYING
THERE, WHETHER HE'S TRUMP'S
LAWYER, THAT'S GOING TO COME
BACK TO HAUNT HIM AND HAUNT THE
PRESIDENT ONE PHASE SAY SOME OF
THIS STUFF TO REMAIN
CONFIDENTIAL.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT
IN A SENSE THAT WHENEVER YOU
HAVE A RAID ON AN ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE, IT SHOULD RAISE A VERY
TROUBLING CONCERNS FOR EVERYONE.
THIS IS A SERIOUS PROBLEM WHEN
SOMEONE CAN'T RELY ON THEIR
ATTORNEY.
>> Tucker: IS THE CORE
POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS THAT THE
PAYMENTS TO STORMY DANIELS, MIS
PAYMENTS TO STORMY DANIELS, MISA
PAYMENTS TO STORMY DANIELS, MISI
PAYMENTS TO STORMY DANIELS, MISL
PAYMENTS TO STORMY DANIELS, MIS
PAYMENTS TO STORMY DANIELS, MISI
PAYMENTS TO STORMY DANIELS, MISL
PAYMENTS TO STORMY DANIELS, MISC
PAYMENTS TO STORMY DANIELS, MISH
PAYMENTS TO STORMY DANIELS, MISR
PAYMENTS TO STORMY DANIELS, MIS,
PAYMENTS TO STORMY DANIELS, MISW
PAYMENTS TO STORMY DANIELS, MISR
PAYMENTS TO STORMY DANIELS, MISE
SOME FORM OF CAMPAIGN FINANCE
VIOLATIONS?
>> WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAID I
DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THIS,
IT SOUNDS A LOT LIKE WHAT'S
CALLED A CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION.
THAT'S WHAT JOHN EDWARDS WAS
CHARGED WITH AND PROSECUTED FOR.
HE ULTIMATELY WAS NOT CONVICTED
OF THAT.
THEY COULD MAKE A CASE FOR THAT.
SUPPOSEDLY, THE WARRANT COVERS
EVERYTHING FROM STORMY DANIELS
TO TAXI MEDALLIONS.
THERE'S A LOT IN BETWEEN.
>> Tucker: WAS THERE ANY
INDICATION THAT STORMY DANIELS
WAS WORKING WITH RUSSIAN
AGENCIES, THAT SHE WAS HERSELF
PART OF THE HACKING OF OUR
DEMOCRACY?
>> I'M NOT FAMILIAR, BUT NO.
>> Tucker: I GUESS WE CAN SAY
THAT THE NATURE OF THE
INVESTIGATION HAS CHANGED
PROFOUNDLY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THIS IS
A FAR OFF MARK.
SO WAS MANAFORT.
ROD ROSENSTEIN DIDN'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WHEN MUELLER CAME TO HIM
AND SAID I WANT TO EXPAND
MANAFORT'S INVESTIGATION.
SOME OF THIS STUFF IS CLOSER AND
YET ROSENSTEIN SAID I WANT THE
SEVEN DISTRICT TO DO THIS.
>> Tucker: COULDN'T HAVE SAID
THIS ON THE POINT OF THE
INVESTIGATION?
>> HE COULD HAVE.
IF MUELLER CAME TO HIM AND THAT
WE HAVE EVIDENCE OF CRIME THAT
WE'VE UNCOVERED, IT'S HARD NOT
TO GIVE THAT TO A PROSECUTOR TO
LOOK AT.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WAS SHOWN TO
ROD ROSENSTEIN AND THAT'S PART
OF THE PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS HE WOULD EITHER HAVE
TO BE DUMB OR AN ACTIVE DRUG
USER TO ALLOW AN INDEPENDENT
COUNSEL INVESTIGATION TO START.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WHERE IT'S EASY TO UNLEASH THE
DOGS OF WAR, IT'S HARD TO GET
THEM BACK.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL AS A TORPEDO
IN THE WATER, TO USE ANOTHER
METAPHOR.
HE'S STILL THERE.
WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT THIS
MOVE IS THAT THEY HAVEN'T JUST
EXPANDED THE PROSECUTORS SO NOW,
EVEN IF THE PRESIDENT MOVED
AGAINST ROSENSTEIN, MOVED
AGAINST MILLER, ED WOULDN'T STOP
AT THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT.